first of all the whole categorization of  like gen Z versus Boomers and men versus  women and Republicans versus Democrats  and religion I mean that's the fact that  we've let that become the framework it  has a lot to do with the anxiety of the  world however this is a major truth we  [ __ ] on gen Z too much up in the upper  Millennial Boomer World these kids have  options they understand how to make  dollars being influencers on Tick Tock  how to make content and social media  platforms that allow them to get ads  from the platforms themselves they  understand there's alternative jobs  they're more patient they don't need to  buy dumb [ __ ] as much as the people in  their 40s and 50s who wanted TVs and  cars and houses they're a totally  different breed while still being the  same which is why I adore them and I  think for a lot of people running  businesses who are trying to hire you  need to understand this bringing value  to them because they have options is the  new game